- How do you stay driven?
I'm gonna ask you a question,
how don't you stay driven?
Let me get this right, you won
the lotto of the universe which
is you are a human being on
Earth and you're not driven and
you're not fired up and you're
not going for it and
you're willing to sit like a
lump and just to you die?
You suck.
(light music)
We're running the
gamut of somebody who's
literally in the Hall of Fame
to somebody you literally didn't
make it in to a first season but
it's all the same thesis to why
I was intrigued by our call and
how we got to the second meeting
which is, listen, there's a
percentage with no question
I'm gonna be able to walk into
mama's house across the country
and win because the ones that
have the best
emotional intelligence
are gonna realize I would do a
better job for their
son than the majority.
As all this digital stuff works
as I have 14-year-old girls
making more money and Musical.ly
with content I'm doing than
fucking first round picks in
the NFL and NBA draft making
endorsement in a year.
I mean it's crazy.
So I'll win that.
I want to surround the agency
with that and so what the agency
wants to is be incredible sports
agents, like really know how to
do contracts and all that stuff
but become the greatest machine
ever in the building of personal
brand and endorsements but
really I think you like this
based on it sounds like your
upbringing I really want people
to feel like in eight years,
10 years I want the reputation
of VaynerSports to be like
you go there because
they teach your
son how to become
a man for real.
- [John] Yeah, for sure.
- Real pleasure, man. Yeah.
- [John] You got it.
- I wish you well.
- Yeah.
(light music)
Cool.
Awesome.
- My name's Tyler Schmitt.
I have been working here at
Vayner November will be
three years, November 11th.
And I for starters community
manager here then got to know
Gary and AJ through
playing morning basketball.
I was taken, I used to take a
5:15 train in from Jersey just
to get to know those guys.
And then one day AJ was looking
for an assistant, Gary's younger
brother, and I said whatever
the hell I can do to
make that happen,
I would love to.
And so I met with
AJ a couple times.
One thing led to another
and I moved into that role.
Was with AJ up until he stepped
away and when he stepped away
I was kind of thinking about
what else to do and Gary kind of
brought it up to me about
potential of doing it and after
doing it for two years,
you know, I made the decision
overnight to end up working with
him because it was a no-brainer
but it's definitely
an interesting role.
With AJ it was very operational.
It was very about the internal
VaynerMedia operations and then
Gary's just a whole different
beast in the sense of you know
he is the CEO of VaynerMedia but
at the same time that's like
one of a million different
things that he's doing and so it
was definitely a learning
curve in terms of speed,
in terms of work ethic,
in terms of hours
that I've put in.
And at first it was super tough
for me actually because I was
trying to operate in my old ways
of the amount of
time that I was working,
the focus that I was
putting in at work and I wasn't
doing a good job which in turn
was tough because I was like oh
you know I wasn't adjusting to
what the role needed and then
just was thinking that the role
was hard and like oh this sucks,
duh-duh-duh-duh-duh.
But once I changed my mindset
in terms of like this is super
doable you just need to attack
it and start working more.
So now, I've been putting in
the hours and the more I've been
working more I've
come to love it.
- I would tell you the way most
people digest environment is
very different than the way I do.
For example, if you think of it
as just a human-based thing the
amount of people that come out
of homes that aren't pretty and
don't have good skylines
and come out and
are straight winners.
I grew up in a townhouse.
That environment it wasn't,
you know, like it's not about
having a foosball table.
The environment is
only the people.
It's not the tables
and the chairs
and the views
and the location.
People are always like, "Look
Gary, we've updated our office,"
and they're like,
"We're like you now.
"We're open."
I'm like, "You're the
furthest thing from us ever."
When you are forced to do the
right thing you're doing
the wrong thing.
That's it.
Either you just
are or you aren't.
This is binary.
Hardwiring,
my ethos, who I am,
is adversity is underdog.
I won the wine world.
I won the wine business world.
How did I do, what
did I do with that?
I left it and came to an
industry where I was nothing.
And everybody made fun
of me I'm Twitter boy.
I have a lot of
Twitter followers.
I'm gonna start an agency and
now I'm fuckin' sticking it to
their faces, right, and now I'm
almost done and another five or
seven years I'll build the
undisputed great agency of this
generation and you know how
I'm going to handle that?
Not by cashing in and
fucking laying on a beach.
I'm gonna do what I always do
which is walk directly away from
it and start a new challenge
where I'm the underdog.
Wait, he can't do that.
That has nothing to do,
don't forget what I did.
I went from the wine retail
business to the advertising
agency, that had no connection.
And so, you know, I don't
know I'm gonna go win a fuckin'
Golden Globe or something.
Mostly seeking the dirt when
they should be
looking for the clouds.
I would say 80% of time,
I sure can.
80% of time people
are asking me for a tactic
that's gonna allow
them to win when
they don't realize that it's
strategy that's got them stuck
to begin with.
Their North Star,
what they're trying to achieve
and so
almost all the time
it's a dirt question.
Gary, how exactly do I use
Facebook to make $1 trillion?
Have you thought about like not
trying to make $1 trillion
in five seconds?
Have you thought about
understanding communication
before you worry about what it
means in a Facebook environment
so almost every question that's
asked of me is a dirt question
and almost everything I do is
predicated on a clouds strategy.
(light music)
How do you stay driven?
I'm gonna ask you a question,
how don't you stay driven?
Let me get this right, you won
the lotto of the universe which
is you are a
human being on Earth.
You, I'm just gonna say this,
I don't think people
think about this.
You won the lotto.
You, in the universe,
you're not some weird specimen
in Mars that does nothing.
You're not a bird.
You know, you're
not a sunflower.
You are a human being on Earth.
You won the
ultimate ultimate lottery
and you're not driven
and you're not fired up and
you're not going for it and
you're willing to sit like
a lump and just to you die?
You suck.
I don't know.
How do I stay driven?
Because I couldn't even
comprehend the alternative.
And by the way, by the way, let
me clarify one thing, if you're
happy with your life and you
don't complain, play Pokémon GO
15 hours a day, right?
It's too many people complain
that they're not winning and
they're not auditing their
actions and realizing that
they're spending too much of
their allocation of time on
leisure and escapism
and that's fine but
work is the variable of success.
Work.
At some level on I'm
just trying to be realistic.
How about just having a
conversation that you don't know
a single person on Earth that's
successful that
didn't put in work.
Nobody watching this right now,
nobody watching this right now
knows a single person that
became successful
without the work.
We have different
levels of talent,
all that but
work required, my friends.
Work required.
'Nother good day,
super productive.
Banging out operations at scale.
Client stuff just a
really, really solid day.
Going to a little bit of an
event here at Hudson Yard now.
Got another kind of
spec meeting tonight.
Just grinding along.
Tomorrow big day, Jets football.
Season on the line.
Season on the line five
seconds into this world.
Anyway, hope
everybody's doing well.
Talk to you soon.